Hello everyone,
welcome to the focus channel and my name
is Paul.
Today.
Rather than get into a new indepth
language documentary,
I decided to do a fun little video that
we can do together.
I want to give you a challenge.
I want to present you with some mystery
languages and you can listen and look at
those languages and guess what languages
they are,
but don't worry,
even if you don't guess the language
correctly,
it'll still be interesting as long as
you share the reasons for your guesses
in the comments down below.
So let's give it a try.
Here's the first language.
Please listen
almost as good as get back because they
know me when I just to put in the sweat,
did look in the dark with some of the
what is it,
what we see as they go,
really?
Okay,
and let me also show you a little bit of
that language in its written form.
I don't speak this language,
but I'll try to read it as best I can
gamble and he went back up.
So what language is it?
The language is Haitian creole.
If you're a French speaker,
then right away you might have known
that this was Haitian creole and other
people,
you might have noticed some words that
sounded French,
but sounded a little different.
That's because the Haitian creole
language is a French based creole
language.
It arose in the 17th and 18th centuries
because of interaction between French
settlers and African slaves in the area
that is now called Haiti.
The majority of its vocabulary derives
from French,
but the majority of its syntax to rise
from the African languages spoken by the
slips.
Let's go back to those two examples
sentences for a second game.
Mooney valley.
This means is there a person here who
speaks English?
The beginning of the sentence doesn't
really seem French means to have or
there is.
It might derive from the French word gun
yet,
but the way it's used as quite different
from the French word and moon means
person and I don't know the origin of
this word is it is like in French,
in French.
The whole sentence I guess would be
India,
calc one,
Siki,
Pat Langley.
The second sentence went back up.
Ballet,
I'm.
This means I can't speak English when it
comes from one in French.
Pop is the French negation marker.
Pop Cup comes from the French couple
color pallet's partly so the vocabulary
has all kinds of French,
but in French it would be like this.
You shouldn't sweep back a public park
Langley,
so obviously the grammar is very
different even though the vocabulary is
French based.
Notice that in the French sentence,
why is not used but is used.
That's because in French was the object
Pronoun.
Wells is the subject.
Pronouns in Haitian creole went is both.
Now I'm breaking down these sentences
just to show you that Haitian creole is
a combination of French and other
influences.
To learn more about creole languages,
check out my video on pigeons and
creoles right here.
Okay,
onto the next language.
Please listen.
Like William helped because it gave me a
this quarter.
What am I going to be challenged by?
Volley ball,
volleyball,
petroleum and Yoko needs or glade
helper.
You only have moved the number from the
leaders from and that's why the egg
before for sure.
Look,
and again,
let me show you a little bit of that
language in its written form,
Bene in Esl scene and more shoots in
streatham clear at all and now he dot
from on his phone on him.
Nor were they.
So what language is it?
The language is Phrygian specifically
West Virginia West Division has spoken
in a northern province of the
Netherlands called friesland.
Freshmen is thought to be the language
that is most closely related to English.
Now it doesn't mean that it's easy for
English speakers to understand friction
when I hear it or when I try to read it,
I barely understand anything but it is
closely related to English and its
historical development and in the
structure of the language.
All right,
let's do one last language.
Please listen.
Like is it just pulls out that.
So it goes under the Jamaican guy.
So I've been buying for Bella so I'd be
there about budget dry.
And again,
let's look at a couple of phrases
visually.
Now I don't speak this language,
but I'll try to read these as best I
can.
Knowing comprendo nonfatal suicide to do
meet this bloody boo.
So what language is it?
Well,
if you know a romance language than you
probably noticed right away that this is
definitely another romance language.
It is actually the Sardinian language,
which is spoken on the island of
Sardinia in Italy.
It is one of many regional languages in
Italy that are often mistakenly referred
to as dialects,
but they're actually separate languages.
Most of them are closely related to
Italian,
but they are different enough to be
considered different languages.
Well,
I hope you enjoyed guessing today's
mystery languages even if you didn't get
them right.
That's okay.
It should be interesting to share your
reasons in the comments down below and
that should spark some interesting
discussion and if you would like to see
more mystery language videos like this
sometime in the future,
then let me know and I might do it
again.
Be sure to check out lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and if you haven't already,
then be sure to hit the subscribe button
down below.
And special thanks to all my patrion
supporters for continuing to make Lang
focus possible.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.